the mayor of Nashville says she will not
step down after admitting to an
extramarital affair with a former head
of her security detail
Meghan Berry says the affair with Lee
sergeant Robert Forrest began shortly
after her inauguration back in September
of 2015
members of Nashville's City Council are
now questioning the mayor's travel
expenses bianna golodryga is here with
new details on this scandal beyond a
good morning morning quite a blow for
the popular mayor Meghan berry is the
first female mayor in the city's history
she and the police sergeant assigned to
protect her both said they did not
betray public trust or violate any laws
and in an interview only with our
Nashville affiliate W tvf she called the
affair a mistake and I'm very
embarrassed and I'm deeply ashamed in
Nashville Mayor Meghan berry was
remorseful when asked about her
relationship with sergeant Robert
Forrest what this is about is being
truly sorry for hurting people and for
for abusing the trust of of Nashvillians
her admission came just days after our
Nashville affiliate WT DF began
investigating her use of taxpayer money
including Sergeant forests travel
expenses Barry and Forrest traveled
alone on at least nine occasions for
business including to Washington DC New
York and for a week last September to
Athens Greece you will see that my
schedule reflects that I was out there
working
sergeant forests overtime is also
getting scrutiny during the final three
years under previous mayor Karl Dean he
was paid roughly thirty thousand dollars
in overtime per year in the first year
under Barry he was paid over fifty nine
thousand dollars the second more than 75
thousand forest was with Barry and her
husband Bruce at their son's funeral
last year after he died of an opioid
overdose he was also present at her
victory speech in 2015
such as my husband brews a rising star
in the Democratic Party who campaigned
for Hillary Clinton Barry has said she
does not plan to resign I know God
forgives but you know the people of
Nashville don't have to and I also want
to ask for their forgiveness sergeant
Forrest retired yesterday after more
than 31 years with the mess from Metro
Nashville police and said he deeply
regrets the relationship which has since
ended City Council members are now
calling for an inquiry into all travel
expenses and overtime pay to look for
any evidence of criminal wrongdoing
mayor Berry said yesterday was obviously
a bad day but she has had worse given
her son's death and in fact it was
officer Forrest who was the one who
first told her about her son's death
this is the third mayor that he served
right
what a story bianna thank you so much